-It's always good to see you,
bud.
-Thanks, man.
-It's actually great
to see you here
because we got to spend
a couple of days together.
-I don't think two men have
hugged each other that much.
-Yeah.
-There was a lot of hugging.
-I've never -- we've --
even on the show,
we've been friends
for a long time.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-We had to do --
take, a couple of takes
of the special for your hugs.
-And Christmas has
brought us together
because I remember
we did the big "SNL" Christmas.
-Those was our thing.
-You won the Emmy for that.
-I did win an an Emmy that year.
That's right, pal.
Yeah, thank you very much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But let's talk about this.
-Let's -- let's let's sell
Bublé's wares again.
-I wanted to hear about this.
This is -- this is --
This album.
You make this album, right?
Do you realize when you make it
that it's going to be so giant?
-10 years ago,
I made a Christmas album
and I thought -- I thought,
"Wow, okay,
I knew there was a lot of love.
-This sold over 16
million copies.
-Yikes.
-This is -- this has been
streamed four billion times.
Look at this right here.
-Yeah, they told me.
-This is the box set
you have here.
-Okay, yeah.
-And then here is --
-Quite nice, isn't it?
-There's wrapping paper in here.
-Oh, look at that
smoldering look to too
that I'm giving it to people.
-Yeah, that's a great one.
How about this smoldering
look here
when you're like a kid?
-What's this?
-You're sitting on Santa's
lap crying.
[ Laughter ]
You also look
a little too old to me.
[ Laughter ]
I want to say maybe laugh
because there are --
there's memes and things online
saying, well, it's getting cold.
I guess they're defrosting
Bublé for this year,
and you embrace that joke.
You recently joined TikTok.
-Yeah.
I was never going to do it.
My wife said to me,
"You're so funny and so stupid.
Why don't you do the TikTok?"
I say, TikTok's beneath me.
I'm an idiot,
and it's the most fun
I think I -- I'm not even
going to tour anymore.
I just want to do TikTok.
-No, no, no, you have to.
But you just
settled the big rumor.
Let's just watch
this TikTok video.
-Sure, man.
I hear the jokes.
I see the memes.
Bublé coming out of a cave,
Bublé's defrosting,
Christmas is near.
You guys ever wonder
why someone
might spend that much time
in a cave?
It's because I'm [bleep] Batman.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's exactly right.
-It's because I'm --
Dude, it's really good.
Let's talk about the special,
"Michael Bublé's
Christmas in the City."
Man, oh man, I was in 8H.
It is a beautiful live crowd.
You can sing, buddy
What a gift.
-I love you. Thank you..
-But you're also very funny.
And -- and we just
laughed so hard.
You have great guest stars
singing with you.
Camila Cabello...
-Hannah Waddingham,
Kermit the Frog.
-Kermit the Frog.
I mean, I was on there.
I mean, I'm just saying.
No big deal. I'm just thinking
of everyone we just named.
I mean, who was the most
fun to work with.
-Kermit the Frog.
-No, I mean, -- I mean,
who is the most, really?
I mean, the one you go,
Wow, this is great.
-Hannah Waddingham.
-By the way, out of all
the people there, you go,
"Wow, this one worked."
-Leon Bridges was good, too.
-Yeah.
-No, It was all you.
-Yeah, it's me, it's me.
-I had so much fun.
Come on.
Nah, you're -- you're
And you know what?
It's more amazing --
You know, I don't know
if you know, that's like maybe
the first special
ever like this
done in that studio.
And, you know,
Lorne Michaels was the producer,
and it was all the "SNL" crew
and the writers and everything.
-He's the greatest.
-Man, he's the greatest.
-Like sitting up in that room
and watching him construct
this thing...
Like, I'm going to win
so many Emmys,
it's going to be crazy.
[ Laughter ]
-I want to --
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's "Michael Bublé Christmas
in the City."
-[ Vocalizing ]
-♪ Jingle bells, jingle bells ♪
♪ Jingle all the way ♪
♪ Oh, what fun it is to ride ♪
♪ In a one-horse open sleigh ♪
♪ Jingle bells, jingle bells ♪
♪ Jingle all the way ♪
♪ Oh, what fun it is to ride ♪
♪ In a one-horse open ♪
♪ Sleigh ♪
-Oh, my goodness.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Michael Bublé, everybody.
"Michael Bublé's Christmas
in the City"
this Monday at 10 P.M. on NBC,
and the "Christmas" box set
is available now.